alright John we're here Hollywood
Boulevard the premiere is here and right
now 100% approval by the critics how're
you feeling about the success of this
movie already well I'm glad that it's
resonating with audiences as much as
resonated with us where we're making it
that's that's the you know the hope you
go through is uh in the creative process
so I'm it's it's really good that people
are enjoying it well you know you and I
were talking a little bit yesterday
about you know those awkward years the
eighties this movie so much about the
awkward teenage years and coming out of
them what was the most awkward thing you
ever did as a teenager oh man my whole
teenage existence was awkward I had a I
mean do you think I got a weird haircut
now I had a 2-foot high-top fade I were
like the rayon polka dot Hammer pants
airbrushed overalls and I was I grew up
in a town about 1,200 people that was a
rock and roll town so I stuck out like a
sore thumb I took a lot of flack for it
but uh in a weird way just like Charlie
struggles in the movies it kind of made
me who I am today I was gonna say it
actually sounds like you had a lot of
confidence as a kid maybe I was just
stubborn I don't know well it's funny
you talk about fashion because I have a
couple fashion questions for you oh well
first of all you've got you know your
longer hair now but in the movie it's
that buzz cut you're known for and I
know your hair has been a topic of
conversation what was it like to see
your old hair cut up on screen I'm still
reeling for the fact that someone's
hairdo can actually be news but I'm
grateful because it gives some people
something to laugh about
man anytime I look back at W footage I
can see that it will $8 fade so
[Music]
nostalgic nostalgic yes I mean does it
make you miss it watching Bumblebee are
you like oh I want my hair to be short
against oh no so that's that's where I
feel comfortable that that haircut is my
comfort zone and it's where I have a
sense of comfort but I like the fact
that I'm going for something new why not
let's try it yes I've been getting the
same fade for 15 years now let's change
it up is it a time of trying new things
job it is it is showing up at a vest a
three-piece suit
I don't know showing up early before
everybody else not being fashionably
late to the carpet being a bad guy in a
movie these are just among many things
that I'm trying this new well alright
why notice the even wearing these
three-piece suits plaid before now this
one what what's up with the three-piece
suits you want to work it's a very
important occasion and I figured I would
dress accordingly no nothing nothing
says big like a vest
nothing says big like a three-piece suit
well last question it is an important
occasion did you bring a date tonight
yes this is the female version of John
Cena and you can't see her see what I
did there
see what I did there that's why you're
funny in the movie in you're funny and
really
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]